" C’est le fil rouge
de la journée
rumeur de fusion acquisition
et de rachat même.
Rachat d’Alstom par
l’américain General Electric.
- Est-ce que le ministre de l’Économie
doit aller installer
un détecteur de mensonges
dans son bureau?
- Il était nécessaire
d’y voir clair. "
Pour la première fois, notre chaîne
a été capable de jouer aussi
d’une certaine manière, un rôle
de contrôle sur ce qu’il se passait
au sein des décisions
en matière de politique industrielle
et c’est ça,
qui est formidable.
700 000 personnes ont vu
ce documentaire sur LCP
ce qui est quand
même considérable.
Dans le documentaire,
ce qui est explosif
c’est que ça remet à plat cette
fameuse vente d’Alstom à General Electric,
un fleuron industriel français
qui va passer sous bannière américaine.
" Quel est l’Etat qui accepterait
qu’une entreprise de 95 000 salariés,
18 000 en France soit vendue
à la découpe en 72 heures
dans le dos du gouvernement? "
Ce documentaire,
c’est ça sa force en réalité
on rentre par la problématique
française et finalement
en déroulant le fil, on se rend
compte qu’en arrière-plan
le sujet est encore
plus important que ça.
Le sujet, c’est quoi?
C’est la lutte économique
que nous livrent les Etats-Unis.
" En 2010, la justice américaine
lance une vaste enquête sur Alstom.
Elle soupçonne l’entreprise française
d’utiliser la corruption depuis plus de 10 ans
pour remporter des contrats
dans de nombreux pays. "
Et c’est ça qui est formidable
dans ce documentaire.
C’est qu’en réalité, on se rend
compte très vite que oui
il y a une polémique
sur le plan français
oui, il y a des arbitrages
sans doute discutables
aux yeux des uns des autres.
Mais en réalité tout ça
nous échappe un tout petit peu.
Vous n’allez pas me dire que,
comme par hasard, au même moment,
il y avait le département
de la Justice
qui arrêtait d’abord un gars,
Monsieur Pierucci
pour bien montrer
que ça rigole pas.
Et dans le même temps,
comme par hasard
General Electric
qui arrive et dit
«je vous aime et
je veux vous racheter»
et qu’à la suite de cette opération
General Electrics
est leader mondial.
Il ne faut pas être des Bisounours.
Deux mois après la diffusion
de ce documentaire
Olivier Marleix, député LR, déclenche
cette commission d’enquête
après m’avoir vu,
même personnellement.
Il m’a demandé des contacts
notamment les contacts
des 2 journalistes
qui ont réalisé ce documentaire.
Et ça a été un élément déterminant
de cette commission d’enquête
et ça, c’est une véritable fierté.
Quand on arrive à faire ça
dans le cadre d’une émission
comme DébatDoc,
c’est une vraie réussite.
C’est une vraie réussite
pour cette émission
et c’est une vraie réussite
pour la chaîne.